we've got some new white house covid
policy and again this was i debated this
morning you know i don't want to talk
about the ridiculousness of covid unless
i'm going to purely
mock it that is going to be my policy
going forward uh here's peter ducey this
is fox news this is an actual journalist
this is a guy who goes to these
ridiculous white house press conferences
led by that crazy woman jen saki and
actually
asks questions and follows up this is
this is a good guy that's peter ducey
um
he is now reporting uh this is from
yesterday that the white house has their
strictest lockdown measures on the way
take a look it sounds like on thursday
according to the washington post and uh
we've we're uh we have made contact with
some white house folks they're going to
announce some of the strictest coveted
regulations yet on american citizens
including according to the washington
post requiring all americans to return
from abroad to quarantine in their house
for
up to seven days
if that is something that they're going
to propose in this speech on thursday
there are a lot of questions how do you
enforce that do you send somebody to the
door of somebody that just came back
from overseas regardless of vaccination
status or testing status to make sure
that they are home and also does that
apply to everybody coming into the
country not just folks who come and
document it uh
at an airport but also the undocumented
okay so that was peter ducey yesterday
now it sounds like some of the measures
that they plan on bringing in
are being leaked right now but i don't
want to go too far on that just yet
because as he said they're going to
supposedly announce this stuff on
thursday so if by showtime tomorrow
they've announced it obviously we'll
talk about that then
but this one that he talked about that
americans coming back from abroad are
basically going to be told to quarantine
and it sounds like it will be
irregardless as the kids say um uh well
as to whether you're vaccinated or not
they're going to make you home caring i
mean this is just nonsense it's just
nonsense they know no one's going to do
it it's all [ __ ] like if you i just
think i've had just like the full-on
like if there was any like bit of the
red bill that i had not swallowed or
snorted at this point i'm pretty sure
after a couple of extra days in florida
uh the last few days like it's just
there like this is these people are
never gonna stop and all we have to do
to get them to stop is say no more i
won't comply i'm going to live my life
i'm not going to quarantine if i'm not
sick i'm going to make decisions for
myself i'm not going to fire people
just because they don't do what medical
decisions i want i'm not going to be an
endless relentless hysterical
authoritarian prick like you'd like us
all to be
but we will find out we will find out
and uh remember all of this of course is
coming from the federal government led
by joe biden and you know he's a fine he
seems fine right there's nothing wrong
with that guy so
obviously they're doing it for your own
good people